[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo je suis ravi de
vous retrouver ici à bruxelles au
parlement européen
dans cette émission nous iront en
albanie le pays est candidat à
l'adhésion dans l'union européenne
depuis 2014 et pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté bien l'albanie
affiche ses efforts en matière de lutte
contre la corruption
notre journaliste mari la bat a suivi
une commission denquête hors du commun
chargé de faire le ménage dans la
justice albanaise l'albanie mais aussi
d'autres pays des balkans veulent ouvrir
les négociations d'adhésion mais faut-il
poursuivre l'élargissement de l'union
européenne
nous en débattrons tout de suite on va
parler d'un clip du clip de la discorde
en france le gouvernement a posté une
vidéo pour inciter les électeurs à voter
pour les élections européennes
oui mais pour l'opposition cette vidéo
est clairement orienté regardez là on en
parle tout de suite après avec notre
invité
[Musique]
voilà pour ce clip qui suscite le débat
pour en parler j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sylvie guillaume bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne socialiste
française vous appartenait au groupe des
socialistes et démocrates ici au
parlement européen dont vous êtes une
des vice-présidentes alors pour vous ce
clip est ce un appel à voter ou en
appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron je
viens de revoir ce clip avec des images
que je trouve très angoissante
c'est une succès sont très très rapide
avec une forme de subliminal une musique
qui génère un peu de la peur et cet
appel un peu binaire qui nous est
proposé donc très clairement ça
ressemble plus à des techniques de pub
pour faire du buzz
vous aurez noté d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya
d'abord pas d'appel à s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales ce que je trouve
d'un point de vue pédagogique et citoyen
assez gênant est donc clairement je
considère qu'il s'agit de propagande
donc pourquoi pas d'une certaine manière
mais dans ces conditions il faut que ce
soit inscrit dans les comptes de
campagne de la future candidature de la
marche
en même temps comme dirait d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron c'est vrai que ces
élections européennes elles sont faites
aussi pour choisir qu'à l'europe veulent
les gens demain c'est un choix à faire
oui tout à fait il y aura un choix et il
sera très important effectivement mais
on n'est pas obligé de proposer un choix
binaire aux français et aux citoyens
pour quelqu'un qui comme emmanuel macron
dit qu'il a une pensée complexe ce que
je suis parfaitement respectable on
n'est pas obligé d'être dans ce côté un
peu blanc noir est expliqué c'est bien
aussi fier de la peau des pédagogies
c'est franchement bien justement à
sylvie guillaume vous parlez de choix
binaire c'est vrai que pour cette
campagne on a l'impression de vraiment
d'une polarisation entre les
nationalistes d'un côté et les
progressistes
je vous propose d'écouter viktor orban
le premier ministre hongrois un peu le
chef du clan des nationalistes et puis
le président français emmanuel macron il
y a deux cotées en europe
l'un est menée par emmanuel macron il
est aujourd'hui à la tête de ceux qui
soutiennent l'immigration et puis de
l'autre côté il ya nous nous qui voulons
mettre fin à l'immigration illégale
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui en effet se
structurent une une opposition forte
entre nationalistes et progressistes et
je ne cède rien nationaliste et à ceux
qui prônent ce discours de haine et donc
s'ils ont voulu voir en ma personne
leur opposant principal ils ont raison
c'est cette bataille qui s'opèrent
aujourd'hui et demain en europe
c'est une partie des batailles que les
progressistes sont effectivement très
attentif à faire en sorte que ceux qui
combattent l'union européenne qui
combattent l'europe soit effectivement
des faits oui ça je veux bien partager
ce combat mais il ya d'autres curseurs
qu'il faut voir et je crois que le
curseur entre la droite et la gauche se
posent encore dans l'union européenne
vous savez je note que cette espèce
d'interaction entre emmanuel macron
viktor orban et matteo salvini aussi de
l'autre côté c'est un peu la traduction
du fait que je crois que le président de
la république française a un peu de mal
à se trouver des alliés à se trouver un
point d'atterrissage et que se créé des
ennemis c'est un peu plus facile mais
c'est vrai que c'est victor banned
hongrie et matteo salvini ita liq qui
ont désigné un peu emmanuel macron comme
l'heure je crois que c'est ça la vraie
auto désigné pour ce sont les raisons
que j'expliquais tout à l'heure c'est
difficile pour le président de la
république française à ce moment là de
se trouver des alliés je sais qu il les
cherche c'est un peu dur donc il s'est
créé des ennemis de prioritairement
justement quelle est la place des
socialistes dans tout ça entre viktor
orban de matteo salvini d'un côté
emmanuel macron de l'autre est-ce que
vous avez un espace oui tout à fait on
l'excès on exerce déjà maintenant nous
sommes le deuxième plus gros groupe de
l'assemblée européenne donc nous
assumons nos choix nous assumons les
dossiers que nous portons nos valeurs je
crois que nous avons fait la preuve que
nous étions en situation d'avoir des
choses à dire et nous allons continuer
avec un bilan qui est plus tôt de notre
point de vue positif sur les choses que
nous avons pu faire avancer mais nous
sommes très frustrés sur cette europe
qui ne répond pas aux besoins des
citoyens donc nous allons essayer de
répondre encore mieux aux besoins des
citoyens emmanuel macron parle aussi la
critique et une europe trop libérale
c'est un peu votre créneau normalement
cette critique
oui c'était d'ailleurs assez curieux
dans ses propos d' entendre qu'il
critiquait l'ultralibéralisme alors que
au point français
ils le pratiquent de façon assez majeur
est assez manifeste donc on va essayer
d'élucider quelle est cette pensée
complexe d'emmanuel macron dans la dans
la campagne électorale qui va s'annoncer
on a vu vos critiques effectivement sur
ce clip il ya eu des critiques de la
part de toutes les oppositions en france
je vous propose d'écouter marine le pen
la présidente du rassemblement national
c'est l'utilisation par des moyens de
l'état d'un clip qui est évidemment un
clip à vocation électorale pour le
gouvernement
au delà du fait que c'est absolument
strictement interdit par les règles de
financement des campagnes
ceci est encore une fois la
démonstration une forme de panique du
gouvernement sa seule échéance qui
arrive on a vu à les critiques de toutes
les oppositions et ce qu'il n'a pas
finalement réussi son pari emmanuel
macron en vous mettant tous face à lui
il a essayé aussi par un autre moyen de
faire en sorte de rassembler autour de
lui
le côté positif et votr de l'union
européenne au travers des consultations
citoyennes qui relève un peu de la même
chose l'enfoncement de portes ouvertes
d'une certaine manière puisque ses
nombreuses réunions qui ont eu lieu dans
l'union européenne ont finalement abouti
à dire indiqué que les citoyens
majoritairement les europhiles qui
s'était exprimé autour d'eux c'est dans
ces rencontres avaient dit que l'europe
n'était pas assez visibles et qu'elle
devait mieux répondre aux besoins des
citoyens pour ses réponses là c'était
important de voir des gens mais les
parlementaires que nous sommes qui
faisons des réunions qui rencontrons de
citoyens aurier nous aurions pu déjà
donné ce type de réponse au président de
la on voit le partenaire de la france
l'allemagne qui est dans une position à
politique interne un peu compliqué
angela merkel qui ne se représentera pas
emmanuel macron apparaît un peu comme
l'homme fort de l'europe
est-ce que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour la france il faut être honnête
avoir un président de la république qui
assume d'être un européen convaincu et
plutôt un point positif mais on ne peut
pas concevoir une pensée ni
des réponses simplement se disant
europhile il faut construire une pensée
politique des propositions politiques
autour autour de ses valeurs
je crois que c'est ça qu'on attend de
nous que notre citoyens tentent de tous
les hommes politiques femmes politiques
et les citoyens attendent aussi de voir
quels seront les têtes de liste est ce
que vous savez déjà qu'elle sera celle
du parti socialiste pour les élections
se chauffent pas mais nous étudions un
certain nombre de candidatures vagal
exemple elle n'est pas membre du parti
socialiste donc qu'elle présentera sans
doute cette candidature enfin si son
choix on verra mais d'autres sont
candidats cette tête de liste merci
beaucoup sylvie guillaume d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur ce plateau
on part à présent en albanie le pays
n'est pas membre de l'union européenne
mais aimerait bien le devenir pour
prouver sa bonne volonté et bien albanie
montre l'exemple en matière de lutte
contre la corruption en traquant ses
magistrats la moralité parfois douteuses
notre journaliste mari la bat a pu
assister à cette opération mains propres
dans la justice albanaise regarder
neuf sièges tous vides bureau délaissé
couloirs déserts
il y à peu se trouvaient encore ici le
conseil constitutionnel albanais la plus
haute cour du pays
mais en mars dernier une réforme
d'ampleur du système judiciaire a donné
naissance à une commission unique en son
genre chargé de traquer les magistrats
corrompus
elle est appelée la commission de
vetting enquête en france est en plein
centre de tirana un immeuble entier lui
est réservé les quelques 700 magistrats
du système judiciaire albanais devrait
passer par elle pour pouvoir continuer
de plaider
jusqu'ici ils sont 53 à avoir été
auditionné seule la moitié en est
ressorti blanchi
bonjour à tous nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour auditionner monsieur
bouchard ccici procureur près de la cour
d'appel de tirana pour les crimes
aggravés
le procureur est auditionné ce matin
après plus de huit mois d'enquêté
déclaration d'impôts actes de propriété
salaires factures personnelles la
commission indépendante de qualification
à fouiller jusque dans les moindres
recoins de sa vie et ce qu'elle a trouvé
la laisse perplexe 180 melek de frais
injustifiées en 1998 1500 euros que les
trois commissaires soupçonne d'être un
pot de vin
sur la base de l'article 35 38 du code
des procédures administratives
vous avez le droit d'être représenté par
un avocat je suis venu seul parce que je
ne pense pas avoir besoin d'un avocat
la commission a des airs de tribunal
présidente procureur assesseurs greffier
accusés et à gauche de la cour un expert
international qui scrute le déroulement
de l'audition
l'union européenne garde un oeil
attentif sur cette opération de grand
nettoyage
une volonté du peuple albanais lui-même
il veut en finir avec le népotisme c'est
justement éviter que que la commission
albanaise tombe dans les affaires de
deux familles on est tous cousance pays
trop petit
mais pour une maladie
il faut lutter public
[Musique]
l'union européenne un intérêt a
supervisé cette réforme d'ampleur
l'albanie est candidate à l'adhésion
une candidature soumise à conditions
cinq points fondamentaux doivent être
corrigés en priorité dont la lutte
contre la corruption
sur les 70 opinion qui ont été émises
par la commission
seulement 5 opinions ont été contestés
par les experts internationaux donc pour
l'instant on a une coopération entre les
albanais des institutions
internationales qui est très forte
un tiers de la constitution a dû être
réécrite pour s'adapter aux nouvelles
règles de transparence
mais il ne suffit pas de radier les
magistrats il faut aussi en forme et de
nouveau et pour cela il y à l'école de
la magistrature de tirana alors ici on
entraîne et ont testé futurs juges et
procureurs avec des procès fictif c'est
une salle plutôt modeste mais qui a
donné des résultats assez productif
jusqu'à maintenant
sokol sa ducci et le directeur de
l'école avec peu de moyens ils espèrent
faire de son établissement un modèle du
genre
calquer sur l'école nationale de la
magistrature de bordeaux est il à chaque
morceau à colle aussi grâce à la réforme
de la justice
il ne peut plus y avoir de nouveaux
magistrats sans qu'ils ne passent par
les portes de cette école ce qui a
changé aussi c'est que chaque candidat
au concours doit passer par le processus
de la commission denquête c'est un
élément crucial ça ainsi qu'un test
psychologique éliminatoires bonjour à
tous bonjour voilà par exemple ici avec
ce professeur
on traite des questions d'éthique et
d'anti corruption des sujets désormais
aborder à chaque cours
pour moi qui ai travaillé cinq ans au
tribunal de grande instance
c'est une bonne chose je n'étais pas
vraiment sensibiliser à ce genre de
questions maintenant même dans les cours
où ça ne devrait pas être le cas comme
ici les professeurs met toujours
l'accent sur l'éthique la déontologie et
l'anti corruption
en attendant que ces élèves deviennent
les magistrats de demain le système
judiciaire albanais est affaibli le prix
à payer pour pouvoir l'année prochaine
peut-être entamé des négociations avec
l'union européenne
voilà donc pour ce reportage en albanie
de mari la battait pour parler de la
politique d'élargissement de l'union
européenne j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau ivan jacob creech bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputés croate membres du
groupe de l'alliance des libéraux et des
démocrates pour l'europe
dominique riquet bonjour vous êtes
député européen français membre de ce
même groupe de la ld eux
et puis jean pierre stroobants bonjour
vous êtes correspondant à bruxelles pour
le journal le monde on voit cet exemple
albanais les efforts faits en direction
de l'union européenne dominique riquet
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
l'union européenne fait encore rêver à
la ligue européenne avait effectivement
peut-être plus en dehors que lors de
dans un certain moment et en réalité je
pense que les européens n'apprécie pas
toujours la chance qu'ils ont d'être
espace de droit de démocratie de paix et
de prospérité
ivan djokovic vous êtes croate c'est le
dernier pays à avoir intégré l'union
européenne vous avez d'ailleurs au début
des années 2000 participer à
l'intégration à la demande d'adhésion de
votre pays
quel effort vous at on demandé est ce
que l'union européenne a été dur avec
votre pays pour accepter son entrée dans
l'europe n'était pas du race était pas
c'était vraiment une
une training pour entrer dans la
démocratie pour entrer dans une grande
famille qui est développée qui a une
bonne économie qui a vraiment des
monstres et que là la croatie a besoin
d'eux
l'union européenne mais d'autres d'autre
part je pense que c'est aussi important
que nous parlons comme nous avons vu
maintenant de l'albanie qu'il y a
vraiment des forces qui voulons vraiment
faire des choses nouveau dans l'albanie
dans les autres pays qui sont dans le
deuil balkanes occidentale ça c'est à
dire que je pense que la croatie c'était
un bon exemple
vous êtes satisfait d'être rentré le
peuple croate est toujours content
mettre dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de regrets oui
oui oui mais ça c'est normal vous vous
pouvez voir toutes les statistiques sont
très claires alors la croatie nous
aimons nous avons obtenu un bon des
choses qui sont très bons pour notre
industrie l'export le tourisme donc
naturellement et nous explique-t-on
maintenant d'entrer dans le schengen
et ça c'est très bon pour notre tourisme
jean-pierre stroobants on a l'impression
à quelques mois des élections
européennes que l'élargissement
finalement n'est pas un sujet on n'en
parle pas vraiment est-ce que c'est
tabou d'en parler alors que les
élections se profilent choc le sujet est
devenu effectivement totalement tabou
le meilleur exemple est évidemment le
débat autour de l'adhésion éventuelle de
la turquie débat qui a été entamée il ya
plus de vingt ans désormais ce débat là
est totalement gelé la seule proposition
qu'on fasse la turquie aujourd'hui c'est
une association un partenariat comme le
propose emmanuel macron approuvé
d'ailleurs par deux autres chefs d'état
pour les autres pays
je pense que il ya véritablement vous
dites un gel je pense qu'il ya carrément
un phénomène de répulsion aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce thème parce qu'on
estime aussi que les dernières vagues
d'élargissement jeu mais la croatie deux
côtés non pas parce que je suis voisin
d'un croate grand élargissement 2004 a
posé énormément de problèmes
l'entrée de la bulgarie et de la
roumanie ont posé d'autres problèmes on
a le sentiment que ces wagons étaient
mal préparées et donc aujourd'hui plus
personne ne veut en parler ni à
bruxelles ni dans les capitales
dominique riquet vous êtes membre du
groupe de la l2 c'est un groupe
centriste qui ressemble peut-être le
plus c'est ce que propose emmanuel
macron on a vu de toutes ses forces il a
voulu que cette question de l'adhésion
d'éventuels pays des balkans soit
repoussé après les élections européennes
l'opinion publique française ne veut pas
en entendre parler je partage qu'il
avait dit c'est un sujet tabou
bon pour des raisons qu'on comprend pas
ce que les expériences précédentes en
tout cas notamment du côté occidental de
l'europe pas toujours été perçu de
manière très positive
je pense que compte tenu du poids du
degré de maturité de ces dossiers
ils ne sont pas un sujet de la campagne
électorale s'ils ne sont pas mûrs sont
pas sur la table pour une discussion
immédiate
on a déjà assez de sujets passionnants
et passionnés pour ne pas rajouter
gouttes de poison dans le débat il va
déjà koktych vous est ce que la croatie
est aujourd'hui favorable à l'ouverture
vers les balcons est ce que votre pays
souhaitent que l'albanie le monténégro
demain face aux partis l'union
européenne je pense que le projet
européenne
n'est pas fermée sur les frontières
tracts alors il faut vraiment penser
la turquie c'est une autre chose c'est
une autre chose de la turquie mais les
pays acp delbeuck par contre occidentale
la serbie la montée d'un gros qui sont
maintenant dans une bonne négociation
avec la commission avec le parlement
naturellement une autre chose c'est
l'albanie la bosnie herzégovine
macédoine c'est une autre chose à mais
il faut il faut il faut aller il faut il
faut vraiment voir si la serbie sera
sera préparée entre et il faut très
sensible monténégro sera préparé ils
font très fermé là le projet européen
sur la frontière
jean pierre stroobants quelles lignes de
fracture on retrouve en europe là on
voit la croatie qui est plutôt favorable
parce qu'elle a une frontière extérieure
qu'elle aimerait bien aussi partager
avec d'autres pays l'allemagne ont dit
est plus favorable à l'élargissement il
ya des lignes de fracture en europe sur
les pros et les antis élargissement je
crois que l'histoire de l'élargissement
c'est effectivement aussi la
démonstration que certains pays ont un
certain à dire moment de l'histoire
entraîner d'autres
la grande bretagne était très favorable
à l'élargissement y compris de la
turquie pour dissoudre en quelque sorte
noyau dur de l'europe l'allemagne pour
des intérêts essentiellement économiques
ou stratégiques étaient également
partisane de cet élargissement
la france a une position je dirais
intermédiaires et aujourd'hui et par
rapport à la turquie et par rapport aux
balkans encore une fois je pense qu'il
ya du côté français une volonté de geler
véritablement ce dossier effectivement
dominique riquet jean-pierre sûrement
parler peut-être de cette particularité
française on le voit notamment le débat
sur les travailleurs détachés en france
l'élargissement ça veut dire la venue
possible de travailleurs détachés un
débat très important c'est pour ça que
la france prenne un peu des quatre fers
sur cette question l'élargissement c'est
à des aspects c'est à dire la différence
de statut social fiscal ou économiques
du marché de l'emploi fait qu'il ya des
problèmes de concurrence intra européens
qui font que à d'élargissement important
vers des pays qui sont avec un gros
différentiel
sur l'europe et notamment sur l'europe
de l'ouest il y avait des gens craignent
ça comme une espèce de forme je vais
employer le vent et beaucoup de avec
beaucoup de précaution des câbles une
espèce de force d'immigration à terme à
très européenne c'est un espèce de
concurrence dans le système et qui
effectivement c'est avéré c'est avéré
juste et c'est très français ce débat
sur les travailleurs détachés à
l'impression qu'en allemagne il n'y a
pas le même débat par exemple elle
situation de l'emploi et de la
démographie sont différentes
vous êtes en allemagne avec une
situation de plein emploi et
démographique est plutôt déclinante
alors que nous on a une démographie qui
est plus positive et aux dépens
situation de plein emploi
on peut pas avoir le même regard ivan
djokovic est ce que l'on jeu d'intégrer
ces pays des balles commence c'est
justement de ne pas les laisser à a une
influence russe par exemple ou une
influence sur beaucoup disent il vaut
mieux peut-être les avoir dans l'union
européenne plutôt que les laisser avoir
d'autres zones influence je pense que
quand nos parents d'élèves seulement
dans les pays des balkans occidentaux
occidentale c'est très clair ils sont si
reconnaît de la hongrie roumanie
bulgarie grèce est ok c'est la ccc
monténégro qui a soixante mille
d'habitants alors c'est vraiment ce
n'est pas un gros chiffre et la croatie
alors il faut vraiment penser je
comprends la situation
l'opinion publique en france je pense
que il faut considérer aussi cette
situation mais d'autre part si nous
avons déjà sept tout tout les pays qui
sont là en europe 1 il faut faire tout
ce qu' il est nécessaire la serbie
belgrade
tirana les autres il faut faire tout ce
qu'il est nécessaire pour entrer mais
ils font très haut rhin jours il sert à
2025 2027 je ne sais pas mais il faut
laisser ouvert les portes
je vais dire à jean pierre stroobants
ils vont y accueillir le rappelle on
parle d'un processus d'intégration dans
les années 2020
2025 voire au delà mais à quoi joue la
commission européenne puisque elle
laisse finalement l'espoir à ces pays
d'entrée et l'a finalement quand on a
des bas on se dit oh là là pour
l'instant ce n'est absolument pas un
sujet qui est à l'ordre du jour je crois
que je crois que les commissions
vraiment un rôle d'équilibriste dans
cette affaire tout le monde considère
que c'était dargis cement est à la fois
souhaitable pour une série de raisons
notamment stratégique vous avez parlé d'
influence de la russie on peut aussi
parler d' influence est de la turquie et
des états du golfe et d'arabie saoudite
dans ces régions juncker parle d'un
problème civilisationnel à savoir
d'intégrer des pays y compris cieux où
il ya une majorité musulmane ce qui est
un vrai problème pour l'europe
aujourd'hui je pense est donc la
commission tient un discours
ouvrons les portes madame o guérini a
mis au point il ya quelques mois une
stratégie pour les balkans renvoyant à
2025 au plus tôt l'hypothèse d'une
adhésion et donc la commission s'efforce
comme elle le fait dans d'autres
domaines ailleurs par rapport aux états
membres je dirais de d'affirmer lé
principe tout en sachant que ces
principes peuvent pas être concrétisé
pour l'instant et dominique riquet est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque comme on a
vu avec les discussions d'adhésion de la
turquie d'avoir ce sentiment en fait
qu'on repousse sans cesse l'adhésion est
bien de voir ces pays des balkans se
détourner de l'union européenne de la
critique et de s'énerver un petit peu de
cette situation d'attenté et du fait
qu'on repousse à une date ultérieure
tout le temps je crois qu'il ya pas de
risque de les voir en tout cas par un
bon bout de temps renoncé à l'europe
pour des raisons il ya deux choses à
regarder il ya la géographie vous voyez
bien où sont les pays des balkans
ils sont en fait géographiquement
entouraient par l'europe sont dans
l'europe
et puis à l'histoire leur l'histoire
aussi que cette pétaudière assez
turbulente dans lequel se croisent les
religions et les civilisations les
alphabets il ya à la fois deux réalités
géographiques puis une réalité
historique
je pense qu'il ya une nécessité pour
sept leaders de rentrer en europe ya
effectivement
une vraie méfiance de la part des
européens faut pas oublier dernière
chose c'est le fonctionnement des
institutions le monténégro tu le disais
et 60000 habitants le droit de veto
justement il n ya qu on tue c'est une
question on voit parfois que l'union
européenne a déjà du mal à fonctionner à
28 aujourd'hui 27 demain avec le départ
du royaume uni est-ce qu'on peut
fonctionner à 30 31 32 où chaque pays a
des décisions qui sont prises à
l'unanimité
donc chaque peuple bloquer les décisions
alors il faut dire que les décisions que
nous aurons que vous avez prenait c'est
toute cette décision mais qui de
lisbonne alors un nouveau nombre c'est
peut-être il faut penser aussi réforme l
europe
j'aime les robes j'aime les jeunes
européens mais je pense qu'il faut
penser aussi à réformer un peu cette
union européenne
je veux dire seulement un petit chose ah
si nous ne seront pas présentées
représente dans les pays des balkans
occidental alors sa culture autres à
poutine déjà et maintenant on a servi
vous avez dit turquie ont beau venir la
chine qui entre aussi en croatie avec
des investissements avec des projets
alors il faut concert il faut qu'on
s'est vraiment sur une stratégie très
claire pour sept pays
jean pierre stroobants par exemple si il
faut revoir de toute façon le
fonctionnement de l'europe de un pays
une voix si demain on élargit et même
aujourd'hui revoir ce fonctionnement
pondéré l'influencent des pays selon
leur population par exemple c'est
l'europe vers laquelle on se dirige de
main d'après jours c'est effectivement
qu'on pourra difficilement continuer à
gérer l'europe qu'elle reste à 27
qu'elle s'élargisse assez rapidement
sans un système étant d'une majorité
qualifiée au conseil pour favoriser les
marche en avant quand c'est nécessaire
et empêcher effectivement le blocage que
les uns les autres peuvent organiser
d'autres réformes sont sans doute
nécessaires le président macron propose
par exemple qu'on renonce enfin au
système
un commissaire européen par pays ce qui
sortent
objectivement je
à la volonté de deux tiers des états
membres aujourd'hui mais ce qui semble
une évidence
j'ajouterai par ailleurs si vous
permettez je pense que cette question de
l'élargissement se pose véritablement
aussi la question de la conception de
l'europe pour les états fondateurs et
quelques autres c'est une communauté de
destin il faut reconnaître que pour
d'autres aujourd'hui notamment des états
de l'est européen
c'est davantage une espèce de grand
supermarché où la solidarité ne compte
pas ou le plus important et bénéficier
notamment des fonds de cohésion donc il
faut en revenir à une définition claire
de ce qu'est l'europe parce que si on
continue dans dilemme qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut pas
rêver l'élargissement va aboutir à un
éclatement complet de l'europe qui peut
intervenir pour d'autres raisons avant
cela d'ailleurs souvent pourvoi
dominique riquet on ne peut pas avoir
justement cette communauté de destin si
on est un nombre de pays trop important
c'est pas possible de partager une
politique commune puis la famille est
nombreuse plus elle est difficile à
gérer mais moi je partage qui
viendraient dit c'est à dire le plus
important c'est pas d'élargir c'est de
refonder
on a des grandes difficultés à 25 le
président bakr on explique bien que ce
projet doit être renouvelée profondément
et je pense que le point de
l'élargissement il est corrélé à ça
c'est pas un projet qui est devant le
point de la réforme fondamentale de
l'europe il faut d'abord que cette offre
fonctionne mieux
je vous remercie à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté de débattre sur ce
plateau vous retrouver la semaine
prochaine un nouveau numéro d' europe
hebdo d'ici là et bien vous pouvez nous
retrouver sur un os site internet la
chaîne parlementaire public sénat ainsi
que la rtbf très bonne journée à tous
[Musique]